so we have some news regarding the Boba
Fett and jungle Fett actor Tamara
Morrison or if I pronounce that
correctly where he is kind of spoken out
against Disney but I think he's just
disappointed and it's fair enough and
I'll explain everything to you guys now
so apparently there was a q a panel as
Supernova which was a convention in
Melbourne and this is what Mr Morrison
had to say I was supposed to be in the
man Lauren season three but nobody rang
me I was waiting for the phone call in
New Zealand waiting and wanting to give
up well that Mando guy stole a few
chapters from my book it was painful
watching him turn up with some black new
lethal Sword and the way he turned up in
my book of boba he just destroyed
everybody I'm sure this guy's uh ruining
my show but I couldn't say anything I
might have writer so after Baron I guess
I think there's a few changes going on
we also come under the big umbrella
known as Disney now do so it's one of
the many previous conversations we had
in La dialogue began like oh look we're
having a few changes we're having a few
cutbacks and while you hear that on a
different finish of the roads no good
attempting to barter any more cash
that's for positive so see what occurs
now I agree the book of Boba Fett show
you should have not sidelined Boba and
it should be about Boba all the way
through now I understand and I get
they're trying to connect all these
shows together in this new big storyline
they're trying to create but two whole
episodes dedicated to the mandalone that
is way too much like having this like a
camera or something but don't have them
take over the show so I can definitely
see why Mr Morrison was upset about this
and then he said it was supposed to be
in the mandalor in season three but that
didn't end up happening like for payback
he should have showed up and took over
two episodes of the mantle in season
three to be honest but to hear them
saying we're having a few cutbacks
potentially he's referring to his cut
role in the mandolin season three I
think that is just ridiculous Disney
have all the resources in the world to
make things happen if I want it to
happen yet they're having cutbacks like
to me it just seems like season three
with a man of the Lord was just a lazy
rushed season in my opinion it was
definitely the worst season by far you
know even a lot of rumors and leaks then
apparently Boba fur is made to show up
in the mainland season three so I wonder
if these leaks were recently correct as
he was supposed to show up in a male or
season three but then plans changed they
had cutbacks and it was removed and
seems like if this wasn't the case you
might not even mean told update about
this which is just very poor management
but we don't have the full story here so
we can only speculate so I don't want to
blow this out proportion or anything
because we don't know too much details
about this at the moment but we do end
up with a book of Boba Fett season two I
hope they learned from them previous
mistakes and this whole season will just
be about Boba but anyway that's
everything about this video guys let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments section below and if you did
enjoy please consider subscribing thanks
for watching